il ya un chroniqueur qui a déçu laura
smet la fille de johnny vous allez nous
dire pourquoi et vous définir ce qu'elle
a à lui dire
souvenez vous c'est vous jean michel mr
et si c'est là au départ laura j'ai rien
contre elle évidemment personnellement
mais nous faisait croire que c'était
seulement une question de principe une
question de qu'elle voulait avoir un
droit de regard sur l'héritage
artistique de johnny qui lui manquaient
souvent une petite pochette avec la
signature de son père sur l'album laura
experts à c'est tout mais que ce n'est
pas une question d'argent et cetera et
dès qu'on commence à parler de
transaction financée de partage la
fameuse maison ou de dons de la maison
de mama coquette tout de suite ça y est
le ciel le ciel s'embellit le ciel il ya
plus de nuages du tout il s'agit
maintenant on est on est copains comme
cochons c'est d'une hypocrisie totale
bon franchement du mal à passer il a un
bon physique total et franchement ça dit
que ça vous plaît pas tout simplement
revient alors je reviens là dessus
bernard montiel un peu choquant là
dedans ses désirs ses stars de la télé
c'est pas si non c'est que ses marques
et ses stars de la télé c'est comme
jean-michel mais le nom là où elle a été
choquée c'est parce que c'est pas du
tout là vous êtes loin de la réalité la
réalité c'est pas une question de fric
c'est une question évidemment qu'à une
question de fric un tout petit peu la
vraie question c'est sur les oeuvres
c'est sur le droit moral de ses lèvres
de l'oeuvre de son père si maintenant
n'importe qui utilise le nom de johnny k
n'a même pas le droit de voir si son
père est d'avis que c'est pareil même
les petites jade et joy
c'est ça qui est terrible c'est le droit
moral sur johnny hallyday elle énervée
contre jong il et elle m'a appelé et m'a
dit mais elle savait même pas qui
c'était alors elle m'a dit mais qui sait
ce mec qui a dit ça que mais pourquoi il
a dit ça
elle tombe des nues déjà qu'elle est
attaquée de toutes parts elle aussi
crucial elle est gentille c'est la
morale tourner c'est une actrice
bah oui bah oui j'adorerais lorsqu'il a
glissé lui ces merdes
il est grave mais non elle est actrice à
le tourner je veux dire l'attend pas ça
pour vivre et maîtrisez pas aujourd'hui
je dirais oui c'est vrai alors merci en
tout cas bernard montiel oui allez on a
eu un feu ou quoi non halal elles ne
connaissaient pas donc comme j'ai dit
j'ai délaissé mon père j'ai dîné sympa
t'inquiète pas il a l'air comme ça mais
non créés bien bas merci bernard
wauquier info